[Music]
it's
[Music]
hello everybody this Dragon Quest music
is so epic and loud hi um hi
Persia here we are back happy Wednesday
Matt is joining us because you guys
already know he is our dragon class
extraordinaire Bobby though I just
really like Dragon Quest and today today
the day of days um nintendo eshop
dropped the dragon quest 11 demo in the
store what's actually cool about this
demo is that what you play here you can
actually transfer over to the full game
later so you made sure to make sure Matt
was on I started this on the ps4 and
when I heard about the switch version I
was like are you kidding me already sick
like 15 hours of this game and I know it
because it's got all these cool extras
and stuff I wonder if you'll be able to
see some of that in here but you know
we'll see and everyone in chat welcome
back it's so good to see you always see
crime in the chat what's up crime we got
there Jameer gauge not rookie so yes the
demo is now live on switch go and
download it it's like a little bit over
4 gigs or so yeah but worth it so I
think we are gonna jump right in
shall we venture forth yes let us
venture for it oh yeah venture Oh what
should we name ourselves well this is
your account technically my folks are
you guys don't get a choice so I named
all my G RPG characters Rohan for some
reason I don't know I just kind of
thought it sounded cool part of me was
like is that from like Lord of the Rings
and I'm like no I don't know if I got it
from there either
it's a girl brother yeah oh yeah there
we go
that my my tional lore yeah every
character I started every game Kinsey
and frequency i gave me what is
so these are some of the extra votes so
like you know we'll just start in the
you could play the game as it was back
then or you could play in classic 2d
mode wonder if you can switch oh yeah
later because well I think in this demo
it's one or the other because it says
both votes are both modes are available
in the retail so for the demo you might
only be able to pick one or the other
right right what do we think what do I
mean I mean do you want to see how it
looks like on switch right see the kind
of the visual fidelity what do you want
to go old-school maybe we should give
the chat like 30 seconds to catch up and
then you guys let us know what you want
to see quandary hello Bob Jones what is
that he says say the title of this game
five times fast
um was the full title again Dragon Quest
11s echoes of elusive age
Dragon Quest 11s echoes so many words
jeez honestly when I was making the
stream and I had to think of a title I
was like alright so we already have one
vote for 3d you got three votes for 3d
wanna vote for 2d or 3d bit somebody on
the chat said that only three oh my god
you're right oh maybe motivation was it
what are you presenting it like this you
had me fooled for a second what a tease
and you can hover over both so it's like
yeah yeah just kidding guys it's all
gonna be in 3d today but we need the
full version for switch releases on
September 27 so you have a little bit
over a month until we can actually see
both versions sorry guys it shows
English voice acting in advance there is
Japanese available that's a new feature
pick 1440 oh man I missed the option it
was by had to do the special code to get
there right all right I am happy with
this brightness setting all right really
want to see how this game looks like on
switch I swear because this game looks
beautiful on the ps4 Pro
like it almost kind of slightly bummed
that I have to restart on the switch
because I mean I don't know we'll see
we'll see you for you expectations
exactly right
Jamil that was a trick question for the
child we're seeing if you guys are
paying attention
you guys are passing a flying colors
I'll keep it up guys it great oh yeah
maybe give us a little bit of Laura here
for those who don't know anything about
Dragon Quest well luckily since Dragon
Quest is kind of like fall fantasy work
each game is kind of stand-alone thing
people are able to can just sort of jump
into this without having to worry too
much about any of the previous games
that said this game in particular you
know it kind of follows a pretty simple
fantasy kind of trope premise two plays
a what is it I mean you will see you'll
see some of some of that in the
cutscenes here but you'll you play as
this this boy he was destined to be you
know this this legendary hero he's he's
a luminary which is like this like
powerful warrior that like you know
legend is foretold in the whole thing
you know he's the son of a at least I
think he's the son of the son of a royal
family was then you'll see later on he
gets brought up humbly by a small
village and then he's off to an
adventure a true hero story look at I
was Oh cute little Carl on the top of
his head oh my god the first time I
realize like Toriyama can draw some
adorable babies let's see crime says
Matt what's your top new cool things in
this version maybe reworked sound
question right I really I mean
unfortunately this is just the demo so
having had the chance that the dive
right into full thing but what gets me
super hype is the 2d mode admittedly
just because that was like a really that
feature was in the dragon quest 11 3ds
version in Japan which is a Japan only
thing which you know yeah but now we
have access to this school teacher that
was in it honestly I think
I try to remember how they featured it
in that in that game I think it was like
the map mode on the top screen of the
3ds but it seems to be kind of like a
full-fledged thing here oh snap I will
say though this cutscene is pretty
beautiful yeah looking at the water
we're riding on it oh wait impressed yes
on the switch it really went for it with
this latest Dragon Quest I'm really
impressed with the production values
Jameel says I love that it looks like
Dragon Ball with Final Fantasy gambling
yeah some little bit of Crillon vibes
from that baby you know see what you
mean the bald head it really had a cute
curl eventually grew some hair though
which is I think that was an android 18
was like you need to get it you need to
get this ball thing isn't doing it the
baby what's that sound
secret Easter Egg those actually mad
voice acting ooh
Parker Thompson asks Matt what's your
favorite Dragon Quest title are we
asking game are we asking title because
the title of this game is crazy man let
me hey if I've answered both questions
well fine fair drank what so far I won't
I'm really so right now I'm actually
playing dragon quest for on the 3ds the
remake that they are the dds actually
they made it remake back in the day and
that's been a lot of fun that one's
really cool because you know you play
different perspectives different
characters and then in each chapter and
then it all culminates into this final
like or instead this like larger open
chapter at the end where you have
everybody together in a party so that
game is real cool I forget if it has a
subtitle so no if it sounds it's cool I
don't know 11 echos even to loose echoes
in lieu of an elusive age I really like
that title though we're talking titles
here that sound pretty legendary
and hmm okay all right look in the
visual fidelity here it's not so bad
could see some jaggies I wonder if it
looks a little better a little better in
the 720 and portable right oh man I love
how Dragon Quest games are localized
with British actors because it just
gives it like a different feeling you
know nothing the usual kind of crowd of
people they get from you know like sort
of the typical anime crowd right folks
like Steve bloom at Mercer and all that
stuff so it's refreshing I really like
that about dragon class that they
specifically do this respect the dog
engine he gets invented the music is
pretty intensely oh ooh this is the
orchestrated version actually yeah I
think yeah it definitely sounds like
that hmm okay something like grass could
be better
sorry I'm just constantly hmm I'm gonna
play this game anyway and just just just
just observing don't keep them waiting
dear should I just be my god some more
unless you're gonna kill me my choppa
folks or the pretty pink speech bubbles
above their heads like me man it's like
also kind of fourth-wall breaking it's
like yeah I know I have a prompts
telling you come and talk being over in
the distance where's the puppy he's
across the bridge hey dog gube says is
this a new smash oh man yeah here they
may be on the new direction
[Music]
we have here puppet where's your you are
you taking us I know right it's an
interesting little mountain hearth be
casting a spell on me and our skin
Harry Potter is ruined me Bob Jim says
get the game Spock voice crew together
yeah we're gonna create the voice lines
for all the NPC's think that's an Irish
or Scottish accent I'm not culturally
sound enough to make that decision
unfortunately I'm trying to base it off
of like my she's like was I've been
watching this Netflix show called Derry
girls which is like the interesting show
where it takes place like in the 90s in
Ireland didn't like it's still kind of
in the turmoil of like kind of the
military conflicts down there the IRA
and stuff but it's like it's basically
like a teenage pop like teenage comedies
just like these teenage girls who are
just trying to live life in this this
this war in that sort of time and
getting on sort of antics and monsters
they're like cutest looking like dude
that is straight-up like every time I
play Dragon Quest like that the monsters
is really cute and I feel bad okay you
know what you've crossed the line slime
slime it's over
good you can't just do that alright my
poker is attacking to you oh yeah says
whoa is that mat back in the stream room
good to see you bud you too buddy
Wow then with the cosign I agree we need
more mat streams honestly Ben was like
Dragon Quest 11 demos out like that
where are you at I need you dream I'm
glad to be here cuz I love Dragon Quest
oh my gosh ahsoka say aversions popping
I like it I got a buddy I mean him
you're always just like just like hum
this song out loud all the time you know
video game music holds special part in
your brain aside from all the other
things you know and learn that makes me
crazy Australian yeah Steve Irwin you
know yeah ya know
now the question of the accent is even
more it's more complex maybe she was an
Irish woman raised in Australia and then
transferred into the Sultan universe not
this asks what do you guys think of
Gamescom so far hmm you know it's okay
nothing too crazy that's like kind of
appealed to me personally that said I
have a very distinct certain preference
of certain games like well okay actually
okay let let me back that up that's
trending that's ratings cool yeah that's
that's a crazy-looking what's that game
about I mean I kind of know a little but
every single time it's just Kojima's
just feeding us droplets of just a
little just what that might be
honestly you know jeff has a cameo in
there and now I'm like man it is not
outside the realm of possibility that I
could possibly be in a game one day
that's true that's true humor will just
hit you up he's like hey I want you to
be in my game only and it's crazy
because we actually did this article
because like he's you know this kind of
likes seeing Geoff Keighley in there
kind of made it like makes sense why all
these people have been visiting Kojima
Productions in Japan because it like
they were it seems like they were face
scanning so if that's true then what is
it like soccer I want to go visit the
band of churches went to visit
so like maybe they'll be in the game
that'd be funny that's the soccer I in
there though he wondered what he would
be doing sneak up but try to surprise
them oh yeah that's right the classic
stuff yes
all right slime gonna sneak up funny all
right bro your face end of your face I
mean there I don't know if they blink so
they could be you know blind can only
see much I love that slimes faces they
like it's funny there's such a married
creature cos like they're kind of cute
but then they also have this really dead
looking face like the stare in their
face like they look like they can just
penetrate your soul right that's there
but yeah they'll turn you into one of
them yeah exactly or something mana
slime degrade though like I've got my
girlfriend into Dragon Quest recent
recently through build Dragon Quest
builders - yeah yeah yeah fantastic game
you like Dragon Quest or don't like
dragon boys I would like to be
interested would be interested to try
see what Dragon Quest is all about
that's an interesting game to to get
into it on because it shows like the
charm of the series without being like
fully RPG so if that's like a thing
that's kind of you know turned you away
that said it's kind of basically
Minecraft but better better in my mind
let me see that
but anyway I got her into Dragon Quest
do that and she loves slimes now she
thinks they're adorable they're super
cute of course I hope she's not watching
because I'm getting about to say like
maybe I'm thinking maybe I should get
her a slime plushie for her birthday
[Music]
recent thing you know it's me kind of
getting on that now VIN said nothing too
crazy from Gamescom we got yakuza wall
to wall you oh my gosh it's like it's
like that question if you ask me like
what games I like playing or like what
music I like it's just it triggers
insanity
but yes oh my gosh the Yaak is a
remastered collection as a yok is a fan
I'm really excited to finally be getting
that even though it was it so it's
coming out in like a like in bits right
right it's it's Hyuk as a collection you
can get it now you get yok as a three
right now on that the remastered version
of that but then you have to wait a
little bit you get Yaga's a four which
is because it give or take October I
think was the date better November yeah
a few months yeah and then in office of
five is you know but I guess that makes
sense you know if you haven't played any
of those games before you know it's
gonna take you a little while
yeah and now is the time now is always a
time play yok is this am that's that's
how we do this oh no okay sounds cons
the monsters here look it's like they're
tapping their foot to the music you know
what was that like crikey he's very very
good me all that goop said I might have
to go through that series someday yeah
please you think he was talking about
you accuses yeah
Finn says it'll take a bit but it's so
worth it I'm about to hop into that that
too I want to check it out I mean that's
what I like about series that have been
around for a really long time and
they're coming out with either new
things or you know pour it to a new
platform right because then they release
like a whole package and then you can go
back why not it's already all nice and
you know packaged together exactly
exactly definitely good for people who
haven't played the games before but then
also good for people who have because
man if that if that those kinds of
packages are always enticing to me oh my
gosh the amount of money that I spent
repurchasing games on new platforms you
know look at this this is an example of
that of what eventually be an example of
that okay why are we buying a game but
even older games - it's like was I got
that Assassin's Creed Ezio collection
when back then when I first came out I
didn't need to get this again someone
said it earlier in chat but yeah there's
just so many games coming up on top of
everything else yeah yeah difficult to
go back and catch up on a whole series
like that in the way that it deserves
you know exactly telephone life like see
says what controller are you using I'm
using joy console I've personally like
that little joy Khan converter
especially for some Tetris 99 I think
it's great oh yeah
like having a dedicated button for each
direction and instead of like a d-pad
yeah yeah exactly really nice though you
know some games wish I had d-pad the
d-pad enjoy Khan that's why I got this
thing which Corey d-pad controller so I
can play games like blazing chrome which
that sick contra like game that came out
I think that game's hard yeah that gave
me sorry that was trying to destroy the
game on the stream
that's just the nature of those retro
games oh it's like you're born with the
the gene to be good at those games
you're not right exactly I was not yeah
it just takes a long time
play it dialogue learn the pattern get
some memory you know muscle memory in
there exactly right Oh find a pretty bad
bad monster dude right windy and it's
windy monster behavior windy smoke
monster it's more monsters I think it's
time for a bit of a battle battles a
duel sneered
oh my gosh we need to get this checked
the small check joke small miss yeah you
smug how do you hit Smaug how do you get
smile what the heck
who is who is not getting their car
checked why is there so much smog in the
air pollution this is terrible
give them a citation immediately
seriously this is this is not right
harming the planet man are poor planning
you guys yeah
hate to get too real right now but it's
very sad you know we got to talk about
those issues you know yeah I just feel
bad for the Amazon and I feel worse
because I also feel like what what like
actually can I do to help right that's
not just like donating money somewhere
sometimes I feel I can all donate to a
cause but I'm not exactly sure where
that's going or or how much it's really
helping at the end of day because once
it once it's contributed I feel like I
rate that I still feel like I'm not
helping it's a big problem to struggle
but I'm sure we'll get there just need
to will you try this two-handed sword
sleeves asks boki oh my gosh I do yeah
let me see if I got that lamb didn't
orator a leek asked how big is the demo
it's a little bit more than four gig
yeah so not too bad but I think the
switch in general doesn't have too much
space to work with yeah that's true
that's why I kind of been falling on
playing like games physically we're
getting physical copies and stuff just
cuz well it depends like you know for an
indie game I'll be out by that digital
even if as a physical or something like
that you know great
it's just you know when you get in the
game or is it like was Dragon's Dogma
was on sale recently and I was like
should I get that when I was like oh my
gosh there's 14 gigs I have to clear up
the games on my switch I mean you can
put a memory crane that's true that's
true but even so because I'm terrible
and I still install so many games and
I'm like but I want that still on there
they have to do that the whole
management game thanks rally eventually
you know you're not gonna be able to
leave anything you're just like all of
them so much she's gonna have to get a
memory great right right just do it you
know what Christmas coming up if I get
you in Secret Santa I don't know if you
guys do that but we like to do organize
yes that was the trouble from last time
so nobody was there to really organize
it all right here's a great sword
pretty great this sword it is alright
hopefully I'm not missing out on any
items like medicines and why not oh here
we go
shiny yeah like the China stuff I got a
pink pine I have no idea no it was very
blue
yeah they got to use for like crafting
and stuff cuz you can like refine
weapons later on wine here oh snap he
seems to be running pretty good on duct
so far yeah the game always ran at 30
anyway I think or did it I'll try to
remember it all made it's been a while
now I'm of no use this waits at the top
watch your step yeah that's very thin
ledge yeah yeah the classic video game
like back to the wall honestly that I
don't know if I could walk a ledge like
that yeah that's actually terrifying
yeah you know what game did this did
this the best though legend of zelda
winwaker when you see link just like
inching his way through because he's got
this look on his face he's like sneaking
well it's it was it's daring when he's
like sneaking and do that one like base
like huh sure if you play wooden but
there's this part where you're sneaking
there's like a stealth area and he's
just got this like you know raises his
eyebrows like
it's fantastic
but that said rank was 11 doesn't okay
ledge ledge animation you know it some
enemies huh
gonna use this great sword oh yeah I
could take and sprint oh okay this one
second place oh wow Brantley says I keep
seeing in chat that the demo is ten
hours long if you talk to everyone and
try to get every little thing then is a
one very long demo yeah I really
appreciate the fact that they gave us
the ability the Head Start need to get a
head start on this yeah you know that
helps yeah like myself specifically
three hours plus that's really good yeah
honestly there was a while of their like
back in the xbox arcade days and stuff
like that where they would have demos
for all the games and I would just go
through and download all the demos and
play them all right they're all free
sharing I have to get like a magazine
anymore to get the demo disc you could
download it yeah totally I was the same
way when I had when you could finally
get the option to do that oh no oh no
she's pretty strong hanging on just that
one hand yeah that's amazing grip
strength okay you know there was a
handicap there cuz it's raining I felt
sure she got pulled herself up come on
this big bird no oh wait the power of
the luminary I'm a magic dude Oh
[Music]
shocking I don't know
my hand didn't just light up very good
she's observant I like that that is like
the coolest birthmark anyone could have
okay
good later yeah bigger fish to fry
bigger bird Colonel Sanders origin no
dinner for me Bob Johnson I do come on
man I'm hungry
San Francisco food ain't cheap beer all
right I need I need that two-piece and a
biscuit says good you're right
[Music]
it's delicious that's from that one
place over around right some sik ryeom's
that's who beat yeah yeah by your dragon
quest mixtape MC gamma
yo up with the dragon cruise oh it's a
beautiful Sun yeah I think I think I can
I can work with this visually you know
and it's like on the go yeah it's hard
to argue against that I mean JRPGs are
so long you know so yeah it definitely
works any way to go
and on and always yes that's you oh no
it's a sound like a sick mother sick
Ryan sick bar right there go on and on
[Music]
it's an important lesson so if you
guys'd know they're they're undergoing a
trial of sorts if another grown-ups oh
boy
can't wait to be a grown-up are you
ready to pay your taxes we're being fine
oh yeah right
Scottie the savage says hey what are you
guys playing we were playing Dragon
Quest 11s echoes of it of everything
it's definitive right that is our demo
I'm like does the S come after echo of
an elusive age definitive editions or
before I think before why did they have
to put their poppy it's like a golden
retriever or something
cutie even the little icons look like
those enemies but upside down alright
happy that we we're adults now where's
our rent
where's our wonder if I can save three
crime says cyberpunk comes out after tax
day so I'm not worried oh that name do
you think that was strategic you think
they did that
OS Sam for special for the news story is
says gauge noise dragon quest 11 special
echoes of elusive a definitive version
[Music]
makes me happy it's incredibly awesome
yeah exactly like this lovely music easy
Pleasant British accent
[Music]
it's just like you don't even see his
mouth his mustache she's covering Dyer
face big ol nose yeah so why is granddad
so he's never been up there it turns out
this entire time he was a child
[Music]
you've never seen you know he's popping
off now he's like we only got that good
yeah not the only one of the few okay
[Music]
Francis don't let this game fool you it
gets hard like Horry they welcome you
with sweetness all right let's go home
everybody Vince I spit done Stan and
smash done old man wisdom yeah did you
see the view booth of you comes out a
million damage just makes all the
characters in smash it like we're in the
revelation that dawns upon them is like
all we're adults now we can't be doing
this anymore
many witnesses ah yes back home the
coming of age ah adulthood yes yes
oh wait don't walk too fast now that
you're an adult your knees not as good
as they it easy I can't be running
around like a little child look at my
lovely voice it's your horse but it
recognize the loveliest horse in the
tank I'm sorry I'm just admiring your
horse you didn't need to be so okay fine
go to the shop against these doors I
have to go back to my house orchestrate
soundtracks really doing it for me now I
was thinking that I might just keep it
to Metis because I didn't have so much
of a problem with it but they might they
might convert me here because like
that's the thing with the Dragon Quest
like community is like they get really
mad when Mike come on you didn't get the
orchestra versions in there it's just
the minis the midis are dumb no like
when I first play it when I first played
the ps4 version I was like I think it's
charming I think I feel like it adds the
effect of it being like a classic bleed
isn't right the RPG right um Tony says
just got the demo from the eShop oh snap
enjoy nice get started man he's a long
game least I'm told it's rather ly long
[Music]
I mom what up arrow welcome back to the
stream and Errol says my favorite JRPG
from last year's smiley pays oh top I
like it
Olin actually brings up a good point
because he said they got here on smash
brothers kind of as a way of like
marketing dragon quest to the North
American and European markets before
they rerelease the game on switch and I
think that's smart
I like when companies do that because
then when I see cool characters you know
or you know being added to games that I
like I'm like oh is this hope like that
I mean if anybody saw that Kombat pack
oh yeah Wow yeah got some crazy
characters in there who knows what that
could mean I mean obviously the new
chairman here maybe so you know yes hand
in hand also right in the marketing but
yeah I like that people are using games
as a means to like promote other stuff
and you know tease other stuff right
right it's good I mean there's this
something just infinitely charming about
like a cool crossover they're always
gonna be like down for that it's gonna
be so gon like they put in the love and
effort right you know as I've seen with
like how they introduce the hero into
the smash bros there's a lot of stuff
that's lovingly nods to the series and
don't be cheap BAM wow that's how we
have he's ended up so since last you
know at first it was an interesting
evolution of how the community thought
stuff this character because it was like
they're really high and then they were
like what the heck RNG not about it and
now you know I'm hearing stuffs and he's
too cheap Oh
orangey right interesting
maybe then they belittle the win he'll
win back their good graces
Frank questions is charming like that
maybe see odo now I'm being told that I
am the reincarnation of the luminary so
he didn't know about I didn't know it's
classic converse what's up welcome back
he says this is one of the best RPGs
I've ever played though I must say the
story it dragged a little but it still
interests my top 5 best RPGs ever it was
something what what are your other top 5
like what are the other four I'm curious
there's been really only a few like RPGs
I've played but RPGs are just such an
investment in general that even the ones
I played a lot I feel like I didn't get
to the fullest like you know get as far
as I could and like all the items and
stuff like that yeah so fact that you
have 5 in like top 5 tells me you've
played probably a ton at least more than
a week playing our way to accepting yeah
she was really down to be like you got
to go on your adventure now sorry like
you know adulthood baby or no god save
the world I couldn't wait for you to
become an adult so you get it eventually
oh man he's having a crisis before he
gets kicked out trouble nodding off go
for a little walk
nighttime always does me a power of good
nice I'm good not just good but a power
power of good and a double check if
there are some Chinese up here I'm sorry
guys I just got out I got it no let's
see any Chinese pots
um Lois this is what you gave for
kicking me out
oh hey guys I love that that's a good
that's a so that's it that's a Dragon
Quest tradition it's like the way that
you break open like pots it's just you
smash them open that's just it's like
link right so Cazale do it's no concern
for the loving care that went into
designing and creating that pod right
that's hours and hours of how is the
hand work Dragon Quest characters just
don't seem to care but you know if
there's there's some charm in that
somehow I don't know why but it really
is Errol says I hope this leads to us
getting the new in development Dragon
Quest monsters game in North America we
haven't had one here since 2011 oh my
gosh yes that would be sick I'm aware of
Dragon Quest monsters I haven't actually
played many it much of that so basic
drag quest monsters is the like the
Pokemon like spin off essentially it's
like they're it's like they're sort of
formula of making like a Pokemon like
game because you capture monsters and
you use them to like fight other
monsters but yeah like the new one I
think from what I hear stars
Eric from this game he's like he's a
party member he's a cool theif dude sly
cool cool thief but you get to play as a
kid version of him apparently when you
was a kid you're going to train monsters
that's whythe for he's a thief someone
asked are you guys gonna try the 16-bit
mode well we're considering it comes to
find out you can only play the 3d mode
in the demo so you're gonna have to wait
until September 27th basically the
16-bit mode 26 like five weeks we have
the Democrats yeah it'll need every week
from now until then in the demo to start
off strong right right nice boots
yeah I had those handmade too you know
in the village you know well that's a
red star that can't be
can't be a good thing once upon a time
long long ago the world was terrorized
by a horrible monster but then the
luminary appeared and saved the day when
it was all over the luminary turned into
a star
interesting that's my Tsar are you sad
that I have to leave classic childhood
friend potential romance we've got to
everyone how many people are here
well definitely not the girl owns the
horse because she doesn't care oh she's
crying you see those tears it's gonna be
okay exhausted after his long day
Rohan finally falls into a restless
number then morning comes ellipses oh
[Laughter]
this is a bad dream
oh I thought she's gonna turn around and
face ooh it's the outfit stallion check
it out I'm ready for adventure don't
scrub up too bad thank you oh yeah the
guy the grandfather in the beginning of
the cutscene
he passed away
he was a fine upstanding man the pride
of the village you could do worse than
[Music]
you know there's nothing better in
adulthood and when your parents the
whole village is gonna is a gathered
gathered together and waved me off say
goodbye no if I got to use my big great
sword yet Oh interesting degrees below
says about how much new content is in
this version I've already put 150 plus
hours and a hundred percent of their
original is it worth oh my gosh you know
that work I have to wonder for a person
like you though you know like yeah cuz
the amount that you've cleared through
it you know I've been hearing that
there's there's some new story contents
and a couple new characters thrown in
there so that like you'll have some new
content but not sure how much how much
that extends to you how many hours of
gameplay that technically constitutes to
write but aside from that you know they
it's more all the other extras are
mostly you know just like fun extras
right which is like you know as you know
there's the 2d pixelated mode like maybe
that's an interesting new way to play
through the game again if you just play
strictly through that way but aside from
that you know it's just kind of the new
music it's all just kind of cosmetic
stuff really so yeah I don't know you
know it depends on how much how much you
got out of this game if you if you care
to play it again if you feel like you
would want to play it again one thing
then you know maybe it's worth it and
then you know portability is a nice perk
too so
I forgot - dude this guy is a sidequest
he's gonna get can you resist that beard
yeah I mean I can't I don't know I
you've been asked to undertake a quest
will you acquiesce to this request
wow that's fancy I knew you'd help me
out you always paid attention to what
the priest said in church you know that
stuff was about always being kind to
others you're a fine fellow and no
mistake
Wow what would you want and no mister
now there's no time to lose my son's
desperate to get his beloved feather
back hurry on over to your show I'm sure
you've climbed on to your fair share of
roofs but just find something to clamor
on to impress be to jump up there me for
help I think I know how to climb a wall
thank you over explaining I'm just gonna
climb up my ass I've done this 70 so
many times all right so my house is
right here
aha you can visit past dragons rest
worlds in the 2d version what I didn't
know that oh so maybe there is very much
reason yeah that's pretty cool
which train quest games oh my gosh I
imagine it's the old school ones right
[Music]
that's a cool thing let me step in
although you're like I'm leaving anyway
I'm never coming back all right all
right where's that guy where's your sick
beard I hear it here we go got your
feather there you are Rohan it looks
like you got your feather did you give
it to me yeah me the Avenger brother
yeah that's right it wouldn't let you
down you gave me a sleeping hibiscus
forgot what that does sir good turn look
for a purple speech bubble above their
head yeah yeah no I know I know I'm
sorry I mean the rush you I do have to
get going to have an adventure to embark
on
another little jingle I wish I drank
West jingles that just like accent
adjusts all parts of my life Peter is
just like good job on that feature you
glad you have you finish it you put it
up we're just kind of staring packet or
something and just like everybody let's
just do that
I'll just demand that everybody just
goes along for all my jingles that I
have I decided to take a take a peek at
the Nintendo page that has the
information for this game got all the
deets yeah
so some of the new stuff complete the
tail with the new character based
stories that offer additional background
travel to pass Dragon Quest world's wear
outfits without changing gear and ride
and attack with monsters obviously
change between HD or 16-bit graphics
synthesized or symphonic music and
english or japanese voices so lots of
options something for everyone oh yeah
and it looks like you trigger 2d mode by
going to church that's how it wasn't
realized that's good
complete side quests and minigames while
exploring the expansive terrains and
cities of area area snapshots of your
favorite moments with photo mode oh yeah
there's a photo mode can I go for a Mon
now oh I can photo mode now let's now
get that selfie real quick hey guys this
is my last post before I leave in Oh any
waves I love those perfectly timed
thumbs up I'm gonna sob oh no don't cry
you're an adult now
hocus-pocus how's this possible
these like very like totally unaware
take a picture of that I guess sure
that's going on the grim that's going
right on the ground all right time to
head out on this amazing adventure
the soldiers are really leaving I mean
we also guess they bide you well off you
go then
across the land you'll meet mysterious
chuckles creatures that allow you to
visit 2d 16-bit versions versions of
areas from popular entries in the series
like Dragon Quest 4 and dragon quest 8
no way cool that makes me very hopefully
it makes the guy he'd 100 percent at
this game well hopefully yes degrees
below
Dragon Quest position now in the chat
[Music]
looks like there is a DLC pack on the
Nintendo store for this game as well
that was released today it's called the
champions pack download the champions
Pack DLC which includes five sets of
items that will aid and customize your
grand and epic quest to save the world
of odd Rios so you get best of success
set that was a tongue twister for sure a
special gift to thank you for playing
the game a pair of garments said to
bring good fortune to anyone who wears
them and
ding wolf we're a special gift to thank
you for playing the game ok these are
all special gifts to thank you for
playing the game a cool costume that
makes Eric look more charismatic than
ever
baby Bora said have some fun with one of
Veronica's favorite costumes Roedean set
try on some travelers togs that will
show our hero in another light and then
the happy adventure set which is a
packed full of helpful items that are
sure to come in handy over the course of
your adventure it's free oh nice I like
free things yeah we should have
downloaded that I should have looked at
this before it we said yeah well anywho
there is a free DLC pack that comes with
what looks like some costumes and maybe
like a little item set to help you on
your adventure I love it that's good I
don't know about that wolf way I don't
know okay or can look more charismatic
than he already is hopefully we'll be
able to meet Erica during this demo he's
a cool dude
he's more my favorite sidekick crimes is
Erik Kain that's his cameo and dry yes
turns out that our own very own 11 this
entire Terrell says I never realized
four was popular I always thought three
five and eight or the most popular ones
you know I thought that too
yeah I think four yeah there's a lot of
love for four surprisingly it was the
last one on the NES tail end of that
generation you think that it would just
kind of you know fall by the wayside the
same way that on the Super Nintendo
Dragon Quest six kind of fell by the
wayside but yeah for people look for I
mean as you can see yeah right they got
the quest for hero in in Super Smash
Brothers actually he's one of the skins
you can't say bye
without you can't go without saying bye
to me
what did y'all make oh my gosh it's
gonna make what happens later very sad
not spoil I'm not spoiling there's
nothing I'm sure things turn out fine
yes miss Mateus gamespot life is every
weekday at 11 a.m. and on Fridays we
have our community at Friday's with Ben
in John Luke Ben and John
filled for you to stop on by yeah it's
always a lot of fun with those dudes
they get up to some some crazy antics
playing some fighting games and all
other games in between I kind of love
that everyone in this game is cross-eyed
without looking cross-eyed yeah he makes
that work somehow
it's classic of Dragon Quest noises
auto-saving oh yeah this song overworld
theme so heroic
[Music]
Tim rogue says is it worth buying this
game if I played the original well with
the recent discoveries we've made with
not only the DLC but you know the other
features yeah I would say yes some so
jamming the orchestra is behind it I
find that I'm probably gonna keep this
price but you between the orchestrated
and the
school soundtracks probably because
they're both really good I mean you
still get the little sound effects and
stuff that are like right you know
totally Thule little Raven guy maybe
he's got a skull oh my goodness
where this warmest color oh it's an
enemy I think that's it I love the
skulls teeth because they're all just
like it's not all the teeth are there
Anna is also just a giant skull likely
you got the size of your head in
comparison to that school big monster
dude who knows or maybe it's that the
skull of a bandit you should see what
the character design for the Bandit and
this game looks like it's just this big
really buff dude with the goofiest
looking face that's covered by a hood
yeah but he's got big heads I mean it's
a baby
yes well that's his acknowledging like I
won this battle seven gold coins all
right okay onwards my journey back to
Helia or to Helio door which is where
I'm technically from hmm it's another
Raven or stark Ravin
[Music]
see you buddy aw dang my parfume you
it's stronger crime so star even brand
the broken oh I mean that's pretty
spot-on exactly the thirty I had started
wonder whoa with a tail Jackie's vampire
sorry
oh these fellows are stronger Oh fight
with wronged Rocky's um dad spells so I
peel I'm so a thing about Dragon Quest
is like you do have to grind on occasion
with the purpose for this stream I'll
try to be a little bit more tasty but
yeah so if I get destroyed definitely to
surprise put finally leveled up this is
one of those RPGs where you get yeah I
love it
yeah they made the adjustment here if
you level up you get full HP again yes
okay now we can continue no no I was
playing like Ultimate Alliance 3 I was
doing out all the time I'm like I'm
about to die that's good rule cumber oh
yeah and then he like catches it before
it's stabbed some crime says pressure
you should try this game if you can you
will like a lot of the designs
yeah that's already very apparent to me
right now every single monster we've run
into you and I only do I don't like want
to kill them I'm like I need each and
every one of them in a plushie for him
right now yeah exactly
oh my gosh she probably made a lot of
different flushes over the years
drank buzz has been around for 30 plus
years I've definitely seen slime
plushies before right cuz when you know
you started playing this game I think
[Music]
what the goatee they're very well grim
save a little face
noise yeah it's where you go to clear up
unfortunate poison to might have
contracted in your basically like you
know one of those med clinics you just
walk in and walk out exactly yes the do
the demo is indeed free on switch right
now and your progress transfers over to
the full game if you do play the demo
yeah well about that oh man you should
take a selfie with the cruel cumber oh
my god I feel pause if while I do that
[Music]
far away what is that little unicorn
bunny over there oh here we go
oh no they move while you're always so
cute it's like a bunny rat unicorn like
I like a rat it's cold any bunny
good me and like them it's all Smith's
bigoted slimes sorry buddy goodbye I
miss less time and I really believe in
right now I care about my life I don't
know about you slimy but I'm out this is
not my scene oh snap are we doing on
that time we are good we still got a
fresh 25 minutes left
it was streamed today okay okay I did
indeed get a notification that team
lunch has begun oh my gosh I forgot
about that
which will be a fantastic outfit some
good food forgotten we know what we're
getting today I wonder if it's like that
just just heaps of just spaghetti
noodles that carrot keeps promising to
happen one day it's just we keep saying
like yeah what if we just it like I'll
just have them order spaghetti noodles
won't even be any sauce it's just
beginning hey I'm down with that
sure go down the well let me just jump
right in lassie on standby though just
in case oh I wish the puppet came with
you know that would have been a good
help to me cuz I'm just on my own
lonesome here heck yeah goob he says
today is greedy to try this out gotta
love a chunky demo chunky demo what is
he a chunky demo yeah definitely oh this
was like the first thing that I saw
waking up this morning actually like cuz
there's won't anything I know check my
phone in like it's good I jump right
into slack and I saw like Joann quest 11
hello oh my god now woke up and I got
out of my bed like a ninja you're like I
am extra perfect all this now okay and
then I was like come house with me yeah
like my response to you as a coal ho
us I I'm totally down
[Music]
let me spend the night real quick get my
HP going now
it's interests I can ask what statue
from until until dawn no sleeping in no
sleeping in we're on an adventure
I'm a grown-up now yeah no I can't just
sleep in all right that's just not how
life works he's not the truth I learned
all this from seeing that sunset you
know so much just came to me and I was
late I got I gotta I gotta get my life
in order
honestly I can't even sleep in anymore
if I wanted to you're like even on the
weekends my body is just programmed to
wake up like five minutes before my
alarm yeah I'm the same way I definitely
just wake up anyway even if I had a late
night and then just like God dang it I
still woke up yeah I know
check it out we gotta check it out dang
it
before like there's just that wide shot
toad in the water
mano-a-mano right here right oh dang naw
man
rollin is fallen and can't get off
somebody :
Jodie's defeated OD ah and he had five
gold coins oh no we hit back I have
pockets Oh hammer boy oh he was running
away he was like I can't I don't stand a
chance hammer hood these guys ya know
they're super popular okay oh sorry
another dragon crisis monster I kinda
just want to want one of those hips
ya know right good it's like easiest
cosplay every yeah right exactly
good hammer we're like a tan body cedar
so like that and put a hood on or
something that balance yeah as well oh
hey all right
you watching cuties they're like little
acorns over here slice slice a freight
bulb bulb just the frightful just floats
about a little bit that's also the funny
thing enjoying class is it but they have
these little fun like kind of like D&D
like descriptions of what would it the
actions of a monster takes oh sorry
[Music]
yeah I have to have to apologize after
every single time yeah I'm sorry
come in aside
[Music]
is that heylia door plays that hot sake
these days are great they're also
calming they got a cool name a platypus
[Laughter]
cute did you want did you need anything
you lost did you need me do that angry
at all I am mmm this is why I wouldn't
be able to play this game I'd never
level up kill anybody
oh you was shocked he's like how could
you do this to me oh I'm green oh yeah
you're about doing look die I need to
get some oh no did I know what happens
when you mess with the platy oh I didn't
rip any medicines please be dead after
this okay lucky my oh my I need to learn
heal fast
get some medicinal herbs
oh yeah stay medicated stay medicated
how many I like to transfer everything
please all right now let's use one of
those great boom healthy horse time for
adventure the music's great just get you
in that browsing mood of just wanting to
venture out and run about something
hmm whoa what a night a sickle neighs I
got a cotton top and a medicinal and
another car toss
sorry monsters I've got bigger fish to
fry
hello garden have you come far well
you're safe now Helia door awaits once
you're in the city you can find a nice
in rest up lucky old you really welcome
welcome to heal your door this is the
largest city in all of the area you know
you should head downtown for a look at
the liveliest side here if you get the
chance there's a party scene up in this
place
all right off the horse let's go ahead
you haven't lived until you've party
that Huey it's the place to be you know
for you know fresh young grown up you
know this is where you go to party
experience all the experience life Wow
it is nice actually
uh yes I love this little town thing
just gets me just makes people really
calm and relaxed
[Music]
so very busy seems like a big city hey
hey hey you're fun yeah that's this is
what I used to be you know Reina dumb
little kid now I'm a grown-up now
walking in the big city with old days
one day look out old fella
lovely what I don't care about the
weather
I'm here to accomplish a mission walking
yeah yeah look at the wiring the
fountain that's what grown-ups do well
this buff guy I know this is the helmet
well I never
you learn something new every something
something new every day
oh my gosh these buffs oh there's a
classic Dragon Quest design these buff
dudes are used in a really won't you see
that look ready to bust a move we
exactly but yeah there's this chapter in
Dragon Quest builders - or just where
you have to like take care take care and
build up this mining town and it's just
a bunch of buff dudes and they're all
just like super down - like mine and
work it they just it's great for this
hey what's going on we're gonna we're
gonna do some some building amazing
crime said I love how this game is about
growing up and Matt complete opposite of
that he goes back I came all the way to
here Lido with just one goal in mind to
capture a glimpse of two of the greatest
heroes in all of history so Jasper and
sir Hendrik the only problem is that
they won't let me into the castle
Oh sucks you dude I can get in the
castle because I'm the luminary
mm-hmm can you believe it well if I'm
not going to get get to the meet to meet
them in person I suppose I'll have to
bide my time by reading up on them
instead this guy wants a study he wanted
to earn my eternal gratitude
oh man what am I gonna do without this
random strangers eternal gratitude I
really don't know okay I will acquiesce
your requests have taken a look at the
West's the city I think I know where it
is actually good luck thank you thank
you doesn't know that's another jingle I
want to hear it whenever I take on a
request of some kind of finish this
future we got to make this happen now I
think it's Sunday we're going to church
right now hey guys yeah you've got
nothing to do pray pray your cuz I love
hearing be the save jingle which is just
that what is it it's just like a organ
every dren quest you have to go to
church to save that's literally think
you do which you know makes sense right
gotta pray got to be saved saved by the
church we're all we're all blessed here
in Dragon Quest anyway what should we do
should we complete that side quest or
should we just advance the story advance
the story
I don't need validation from the
stranger I will acquiesce your request
later thank you gonna walk through this
this fountain you know it's what I gotta
do all this asks hi guys do you know if
this is coming out for Xbox one you know
I realize that's not a thing I'm sorry
dude like because it was a ps4 exclusive
last year and now it's on switch
unfortunately a switched
Xbox players don't get the chance heck I
don't know if this is some PC actually
dang you thought they were gonna let you
in wow I'm a grown-up can't you see I am
I've lived my life for this and you and
your curly mustache telling me I can't
go past is your business state your
business cuz you don't have a message or
a beard they don't believe
all of it oh my gosh you gotta grow some
facial hair I love this Rohan explain
come this week to the king excuse me I
have come a long way straight up
laughing your face oh my god
hope you know what that means the guys
always check this out yeah proof of my
birthright
let me in doofuses okay wait
waited all my life I guess I could win a
couple minutes I'm gonna have a word
with your supervisor all right come on
let's let's do this my footsteps sounds
when I ride it walking up to the king
like
red carpet nice touch I rolled it out
for me you know they knew I was coming
by sprint see this guy's sprinting like
full force in all these directions
willing I think where do you think you
are young men correction young adults
young adult excuse me that's true
old ayah says yeah fingers crossed you
never know I wouldn't have thought Final
Fantasy seven eight or nine would be on
Xbox one so you never know that's true
well come to their senses and they
realize it needs to be on the Xbox needs
to be everywhere it needs to be oh yeah
exactly everywhere on your phone right
iOS and Android in your Tesla car for
real things are crazy Regal named King
carnelian I love that he rolled his iron
when he said roll enroll are offering
learn new words every day to nature
take a look and if you guys sense do
something a little sketch going on here
I never seemed a little silence
southerners aluminum what a trap don't
tell me where your people live just
motions are gonna happen I'll tell you
right now games have made me the most
like paranoid person in the world
oh yeah it's like all happy and the king
right no my not no I'm gonna burn your
village now excuse me that's my hometown
that's somebody fighting word that's war
come from cobblestones represent
disgusted how does this make me think he
is you know doing Altera do some points
with me that man only I could live life
and be this regal be so bougie but like
oh I thought I was paranoid well
nobody's scheming
I'm not scheming we wouldn't be scheming
about I don't even know what a scheme it
I didn't bring my dictionary I'm just
from a town and nobody's remember not
the dungeon la twist dude that's not
what it is
exactly I get your point but hear me out
grandad
but you were looking out for me I guess
is what it's like to be an adult now
he's learning the hard way
ooh I think do we have enough time to
meet Eric yes we do we have nine minutes
Oh Eric we gotta meet a Eric de yo with
something no you wasn't Dragon Quest
he's gonna teach you the ability the teh
way the teh way take way the attention
to detail of the sound of the armor yeah
it's right big fan of there's a lot of
sounds and games like with your brother
you're like the different like textures
right run on crass cobblestone whatever
it is oh not this Comi sis dragon what's
a persona or better than current Final
Fantasy III you know honestly I might
have to agree with you you know so far
fantasy 15 didn't really do it from
by then we can never be released if I'm
fancy ain't pretty soon that's what you
cool you know that's kind of like
slightly polarizing but still it's cool
hey who's that guy over there
I see feet that's that's that's the cool
dude that's half his body
paid him to focus I wasn't like him
because his voice actor and I know he
sounds cool to me Jake thinks he sounds
lame but I think he's alcohol through
the Cosmo says don't know if anyone has
answer your questions but the girl has a
Southwestern English accent interesting
interesting so they say crikey over
there don't be surprised by Shh keep it
down will ya that goes the neighborhood
so he's kinda like act he's got like a
weird like it comes from the east go
yeah yeah that's everyone's first
question in jail I was just trying to
meet with the King this is crazy
I think he could fit through those bars
yeah dude what slop you got for me it's
green thank you for telling me it is
delicious girl I will definitely enjoy
it
ooh
you pull fast one oh cool dude through
the armor and all that but I know the
luminaries around know I can easily
break out you could've broken that again
either by choice I yeah I just needed a
purpose
reveal your cool hair to me please Eric
I know you have a hood but you look cool
you have spiky hair yeah dude look at my
hand bro through the Cosmo says and
crikey is a regular English UK term
being that many Australians have origins
in the UK the term is popular there too
it definitely makes a butt ton of sense
I think we can all thank Steve Irwin for
making us think that crikey was like an
Australian thing right pop culture
zeitgeist famous Australian alright so
easy peasy we were in jail for all of
like two minutes experiencing a lot in
in Mike's brief time and as an adult
what are you are you gonna he just
murdered that man that murder happens in
Dragon Quest that's you know okay okay
all right didn't kill him but he won't
be waking yeah his accents like all over
the place yeah I know that's like I
don't know there's something about it
that's like charming Errol says Eric has
kind of a New York accent the pin just
dozen yeah exactly because it's it's
definitely a pretty sure his that the
actor who plays him he's English and
he's just kind of going for that I think
so it creates this interesting
interpretations unstoppable
Oh Eric he's like I'm not gonna lie he's
like 50% of it we were like Foom 60% of
the reason why I play this game I don't
know I like him so much
she's the charming young thief dude this
that that's the most drawn out archetype
you could have ever had ever seen a game
like this but he's just a cool version
of that and you go no no steps mmm
Cornish accent so Eric is it Eric have a
Cornish accent you're saying no
interesting interesting Oh either way I
love the way it sounds
is on some Shawshank Redemption where's
Morgan Freeman no vendors through him
though you're rockin without the penny
thing yeah yeah I don't got the oh
that's okay well we did we met Erik yes
we did we got a lot of progress we got
Erik my boy Erik so happy shiny stuff
more shinies alright well I am glad we
got to meet him because we're pretty
much in the last minute or so stream oh
it was a good time indeed quite the
adventure that we ventured forth on and
yeah for anybody else who likes dragon
quests or wants to you know get into it
try it out the demo is free and it's
available on the Nintendo eShop right
now for the switch and it will be
available the full game on switch on
September 27th
so yeah got a little bit over a month
until it's ready but all your progress
in the demo transfers over to the full
game so you have a chance to get a head
start
yeah now's your time anything we want to
say to the chat before we go man mmm
thanks for joining us Dragon Quest is
great I love it and so yeah you should
play it until next time hope you guys
have a great day
it's Wednesday we're halfway through the
week so keep on going you guys you got
this